the Democrats employed an unusual strategy
this election cycle,
boosting far right candidates
and seems to have worked
back in the primary season.
democratic groups poured
money into the campaigns of far right candidates,
the theory being that they'd be easier to beat
in November,
and it paid off
in every high profile race that used this tactic
the Republican
they helped either lost to
or is falling behind the Democratic candidate.
it was a risky gamble,
especially when polls were predicting a red wave
not saying it worked every time.
some of the far away candidates
backed by Democrats didn't make it past the primaries,
but it had a big impact on governors,
races in some crucial states.
democrats beat those boosted candidates in Pennsylvania,
Maryland, and Illinois,
and while the count in Arizona is still pretty close,
Republican Carrie Lake
would still have to come from behind to beat Democrat
Katie Hobbs.
it also worked in congressional races.
the Democratic Party came out on top in Michigan
and New Hampshire
after donating to far away
candidates in the primaries there.